Imagine an ultimate road trip across the globe on a
highway along the equator. Wait,
there there's no highway along the equator yet.
So how about we build one?
What would it take to construct the longest road on earth?
How long would you spend behind the wheel to complete this Epic journey
and why would building this highway upset?
Environmentalist's this is whatev and here's
what would happen if we built a road around the world,
there are about 64 million kilometers of all kinds of roads around
the globe,
but no single highway network that can take you from New York directly
to Cape town.
The hypothetical freeway that we're about to build would easily take you from
Columbia all the way to Indonesia,
combine that with some of the existing road systems,
and you might just be able to drive anywhere in the world,
but that would be a very expensive engineering achievement,
because a big part of this highway would have to be constructed
underwater.
On average, it takes about five to 10 years to build a highway,
but we wouldn't be building just any highway.
We're aiming for a 40,000 kilometer long two lane
Ecuadorian road to construct it in about the same
timeframe as a normal highway,
we need to be working on different parts of it all at the same time,
our globe spanning highway would require about 8 million skilled workers
and some $9.2 trillion to build. Yeah,
those are some whopping numbers to consider.
And what would it be like to drive on it?
I'd say it's pretty cool.
The equator cuts through 13 countries and three oceans.
Let's say you start in South America in Ecuador and travel East through
Colombia to Brazil.
You'd be enjoying a humid tropical climate and very high temperature.
So make sure your cars,
air conditioning is working before you leave for the trip.
You'd be passing over mountains and the Amazon river.
And if you decided to go for a refreshing swim,
remember that the Amazon's full of bloodthirsty.
Paranas waiting to eat you in a matter of minutes.
Just joking Paranas are actually calm scavengers.
So you can go for a swim at your own risk.
Your Amazonian would just be the beginning.
You would soon reach the Atlantic coast of Brazil and you'd be about to enter
the first underwater stretch.
The great Atlantic tunnel and the view here is,
Hm.
Rather doll.
Finally, there's land. After days of travel,
you would make it to Africa.
You'd be driving through the Savannah's Swampson dense rainforest of
Gabon and Congo and into the deserts of Kenya and Somalia
on your way. You might see elephants, gorillas, buffaloes,
and leopards,
and that would make the long trip through the tunnel kind of worth it.
But then you run out of land and you enter another underwater
tunnel this time. It's the great Indian.
In tunnel.
Oh, I see.
And again,
it's Indonesia with it's 17,000 islands scattered around the
equator.
You'd be driving through a series of short tunnels to cross from one Island to
another. And every time you got back on land,
the scenery would be majestic, volcanic landscapes,
rice fields, tropical rainforests.
I bet you could use a day at the beach after such a long drive.
Okay. It's time to move on to the next town.
The great Pacific tunnel.
Is it just me or is this one like three times longer?
No, this is the longest underwater stretch of the entire trip.
And by the end of it,
you'd have a little bonus in the form of the last exciting spot of the highway.
The Galapagos islands,
a showcase of evolution where the most unusual forms of life are
thriving in the wild, a feast for the eyes. After that long drive,
then you would drive a little further through one last short underwater tunnel
and end up right where you started in Ecuador. Hey, congratulations.
You made a road trip around the globe traveling at
100 kilometers per hour.
You'd spend some 400 hours or about 17 days
at the wheel. 12 of those days,
you'd be stuck inside a tunnel under the ocean with some breaks for the
night rest and sometime to enjoy the sights.
The entire travel time would add up to at least two months.
Hope you can afford such a long vacation,
but as much fun as this idea sounds,
it would be an enormous hit on the planet.
The construction of the highway itself would disrupt ecosystems,
both on land and in the ocean.
On top of that during this Epic trip,
your car would emit almost twice as much carbon dioxide as the average
car does in a year.
Looks like we'll never see a highway like that running along the equator.
Maybe we could start building flying cars that would require a different type of
highway altogether,
but that's a story for another.
[Inaudible].